gente o
o convite é a decência de incrível com
encontros incríveis é de mundos
incríveis que justamente nessa diferença
finaliza mundos possíveis e isso lembrou
uma frase da coreógrafa alemã pina
bausch e que eu adoro ela dizia que não
interessava a ela o movimento das
pessoas mas o que movimentava as pessoas
porque nesse lugar e o que nós vimos
aqui foi um movimento vários a maioria
dessas pessoas usavam seu ofício como
instrumento de transformação mas o
sentido não era o ofício em si mas o que
você fez ou faz com ele e de certa forma
é nesse lugar que o meu ofício ainda me
fascina e quando eu falo ainda quando
falam você tem essa paixão por moda não
tem paixão por moda eu nunca tive
aliás eu escolhi ser estilista né a
profissão por acaso me pegou
eu venho de uma família de cinco irmãos
meus pais morreram muito cedo e quando
morreu o mais novo tinha cinco mais 7 11
e os cinco se criar um casa né ea
vizinhança em torno do ava as coisas
então na minha infância inteira eu não
tenho registro de nenhuma roupa nova as
roupas eram dadas as outras chegavam e
quando abrir uma caixa uma sacola é quem
tá de seis meses quem tivesse precisado
de roupa fosse criança de cinco anos ou
17 ele ganhar uma causa de um ancião é
ele rolava uma penha se rolar uma bainha
roupa era transformada e todo mundo ia
felizes em reclamação roupa nunca foi o
problema nunca foi um peso muito pelo
contrário
quando a roupa chegava eu criança de
casa mas não a história por trás
daquelas roupas o que aquelas outras
traziam com alma o que aquelas roupas
traziam o que elas falavam e claro por
que eu vestia uma calça que o gavião vim
parar aqui embaixo é eu falava se não
quem disse estar mais gorda mas olha
isso volto a dizer isso não era nova
continua problema agora que eu queria
mesmo era fazer um curso de desenho que
alguém me pagasse um curso de desenho e
adolescência comecei a procurar cursos
um jornal com tanto os grafites
foi assim que eu aprendi a desenhar
faixa de rua foi assim que eu aprendi a
desenhar o rosto
o parafuso e foi assim também que um dia
eu estava num ponto de ônibus e uma
vizinha estava com uma pasta de desenho
é também um concurso de desenho e eu
achei os desenhos lindos era um desenho
de moda né é uma palavra mágica é
gratuita no curso do senac
eu era adolescente tinha 14 para 15 anos
fim da ditadura eu só literatura
política
meus amigos também todos envolvidos
designa aquele clima efervescente com
base em via naquela época protestos
enfim toda aquela história e claro
escondido eu fui fazer o curso porque
naquela época dissesse que o brasil no
futuro seria o país com maior número de
escolas de moda do mundo e onde na sua
cara
eram cursos que estavam limpos metade da
turma formada por senhorinhas de cabelo
lilás que estavam limpando ensinada a
tentar prender o a fazer as costas do
figurino né ea outra parte é formada por
travestis que sabe prender desenhar a
fantasia de carnaval né e as aulas eram
ótimas porque as senhorinhas levava o
lanche da noite e concorriam entre elas
um menor com queijo melhor bolo de fubá
ea outra turma as meninas levavam a fita
cassete do blush lei bassey
enfim as meninas as amorosas é bom dois
meses de curso terminado o curso nenhuma
turma nem outra aprender a desenhar só
eu eu já sabia da rosca de parafuso e
isso pra moda quase que a mesma coisa eu
estava escondido pra minha história
terminal ii mais uma semana depois setor
de colocação profissional do senac me
liga oferecendo um emprego numa loja de
tecidos para vocês entenderem a turma
mais nova ali o brasil estava começando
preta portê né a história de comprar a
roupa pronta mas ainda é muito forte a
história de dar tecido de presente um
corte de fazenda de presente e tinha um
figurinista que ficavam na loja desenhar
uma roupa que levava na modernista da
costureira que sabia modelar saber
costurar e fazer a roupa pra figura aí
nessa história dessas eu falei o que é
que eu tenho que pagar senão pagar
empregos e vai receber por isso
meu primeiro trabalho gente
o dia inteiro ainda vão me pagar por
isso só que não foi essa maravilha não
que quando abriu a porta da loja tarde
umas 30 mulheres na minha frente com
rolos de tecido do braço alta baixa
gorda querendo a roupa do casamento que
ela rouba o velório que ela roubou o
enterro que na roupa tudo quanto à eu só
sabia desenhar eu não entendia de
costura
claro que está em ter sido de muita
gente claro que eu fiz muito frankstein
mas há quem diga que o windows faço mas
nessa história
o que aconteceu eu aprendi uma coisa que
só a maturidade mais atraente porque eu
fiz um ano nessa loja depois um dono de
um ateliê e ofereceu três vezes que eu
recebia para poder trabalhar no ateliê
de alta costura e lá realmente aprendi
efetivamente a construção de uma roupa
eu fiz o vestibular pra te tura belas
artes mas chance sendo resta instaurado
o curso de estilismo na ufmg eu como já
está mexendo com isso aí eu optei pelo
curso de estilismo terminado o curso eu
participei de um concurso promovido por
uma grande de selagem da época santista
isso 1990 e eu tirei o primeiro prêmio
depois de dois anos eliminatória e o
primeiro prêmio foi um curso uma pós
graduação na pasta em nova york
aí eu fui pra nova distante do brasil é
um de um dia eu estava andando e eu não
sabia quem era cheia isso quem era quem
é quem não sabe de nada
cheguei em nova york e de repente eu me
deparo com uma coisa que parecia uma
galeria de arte como ele independente
com uma roupa muito diferente de tudo
que eu já tinha visto e do lado de uma
portinha você entrar por essa porta você
tinha que nadar no meio dos manequins 31
em cabos de aço e quando entrei em um
pique de cara com aquele lugar era uma
loja que ela era verde água de aço inox
e os degraus gastos de terracota com uma
soleira das igrejas de minas e tocava
talvez de oliveira cantando estrela
d'alva e as pastorinhas quando eu dei
por mim estava do outro lado da rua
sentado no meu filho chorando
foi a primeira vez que eu chorei por
causa
roupa por causa de moda mas eu chorava
não é por causa da roupa
eu chorava não era por conta da marca
japonesa que ela carregar só funcionava
conta do brasil
eu chorava por nós quando eu olhei e
falei assim gente
eles são lindos porque eles pegam a
história dele eles pegaram a história
deles pegaram a tradição e fazem a
modernidade é porque nós não podemos
fazer isso
era uma época que as pessoas iam para
fora sem sem dizer que nunca mais quer
voltar pro brasil entendeu era uma coisa
que tenha ficava de falar senão eu vou
voltar e eu vou fazer
no brasil o que esses japoneses me
provocam né é falar da cultura deles
levar a cultura deles para até os
mínimos botões que eles colocam a roupa
né e claro não tem como a gente não citá
a italiana lina bo bardi que caiu de
amores pelo brasil e disse que sonhava
com o dia em que as cadeiras para se
sentar as casas para se morar e as
roupas para se investir
desenhadas por brasileiros trouxesse um
mínimo da grandiosidade da cultura desse
país
aí eu falei pronta é aqui na volta o
brasil em 96 e aí com a maturidade eu
fui entender que a minha verdadeira
escola foi à loja de tecidos porque foi
ele que eu aprendi que por trás da
escolha de uma roupa tem sempre uma
conquista amorosa conquista amorosa com
seu grupo
uma conquista amorosa com você conquista
amorosa com seu tempo
então assim roupa não é só a roupa fala
copa pensa roupa escrita a palavra e
quando você olha por aí se pode falar de
tudo o sobretudo com a roupa
hoje 44 desfiles depois eu posso sentar
aqui pode ficar dias contando a história
de cada coleção o que deu certo eo que
deu errado o processo de pesquisa mas
principalmente uma coisa que é
extremamente valiosa para mim com os
lugares que o ofício levou as pessoas
que o ofício fez com que eu encontrasse
e mais do que ele
é isso tudo é me sentir um homem do meu
tempo através de uma coisa de uma
profissão pela quase morri de vergonha
porque moda um país com tanto problema
tinha que vai mexer com moda quem mexer
com roupa né com tanta coisa mais séria
para ser feita e foi através desse
trabalho que eu peguei a cartilha de um
dos meus mentores intelectuais que é
mário de andrade e fui ser turista
aprendiz no brasil
foi assim que é eu fui pro nordeste
foi aí que eu fui a investigar saberes e
fazeres em vias de extinção
foi aí que eu fui jogar luz com a mídia
espontânea que esse vetor tem que a moda
em cima de de comunidades que precisavam
antes de qualquer coisa um estímulo e
autoestima ligada àquele trabalho que
faziam foi assim que eu fui na amazônia
desmatada trabalhar com o que restou
ali e só sementes e trabalhar como fazer
biojóias
foi assim também que eu entrei num
universo de grandes nomes e filósofos
que nasceram nesse país que nos deram
obras 15 mas que nos ensinam diariamente
como guimarães rosa
caso um monte de andrade graciliano
ramos
foi assim que eu fui para são borja na
divisa do rio grande do sul com a
argentina e descobrir a maravilha que é
zaha artesanato feito com crina de
cavalo é que lá é de cavalo bem estatuto
de ouro na mão daquelas meninas e foi
assim também que eu olhei a frança marca
do país né falei disso tentei fazer
mostra meus seus nós do nosso tempo como
a última coleção nem que falamos de
transfobia
é o brasil é hoje o país que mais mata
travestis e transexuais no mundo
e foi assim que eu aprendi que a moda
tem poder e violência disse mesmo que é
enxergar poesia em terreno área
ela consegue no terreno a
olhar aquela direita não aqui dá pra
nascer uma semente e essa semente da
árvore ela florence e ela dá algo que
nenhum governo corrupto tira do povo que
a autoestima
então é mesmo é nesse lugar que eu acho
que a moda pode ser transformadora é
nesse lugar que ela pode mudar o olhar
transformar o olhar e no início falavam
muitas então você tá você busca a uma
moda a posição de uma moda brasileira
eu sou brasileiro tom zé brasileiro
impunemente
não é por acaso um país extremamente
inspirador
a então você vê que é que a moda seja
entendida como arte também não tem gente
que cozinha né que têm chefes que são
ganha estatuto de artista como o nosso
amiguinho falou que mais cedo né
e tem outros que não só fazem comida mas
uma coisa assim
a moda é cultura então minha batalha
desde sempre ela fosse entendida como um
vetor cultural assim como arquitetura
assim como a gastronomia am e esse
cultura é algo que você não veste e sai
para a rua mas é o que sustenta que
sustenta a vestir o que você quiser ser
o que você quiser ser o governo
brasileiro passou a entender a moda
cultura em 2011 e mas até aqui
a moda sempre foi aquela não é que
dormia com teatro era amante do cinema
chegou a fazer um sexo oral com a
literatura e com a poesia né
mas ainda assim é aquela que só quer
saber de dinheiro e agora não
esse ano o ipc a apreciar o prêmio são
paulo dos críticos paulistas
nossa associação paulista dos críticos
de arte pela primeira vez eles premiaram
a moda né eu fui premiado como estilista
e foi uma vitória não só desse desses
anos batalha mas principalmente para
todo o setor porque ele já estava lado a
lado com os vetores da cultura
brasileira e no mundo contemporâneo sim
a moda
a gastronomia arquitetura são vetores
que vamos dar sustentação a escrever
para transformar e pra redesenhar o
mundo de uma outra forma não é gente
muito obrigado mesmo
[Aplausos]